because you're sincere you're sincere
and you just of all the Muslim Brothers
here you're the guy I respect alah but I
say to you Jesus I'm not talking about
his background I'm talking about his
belief system his belief system he
submitted to God according to God's
teaching this what Islam Islam brother
brother Islam came 600 years after Jesus
Jesus had the Passover Jesus practiced
his culture everything was was Jewish
but he came with a new teaching I don't
you know me I don't believe in the
Trinity you know I don't believe in you
know I don't believe in the Trinity I'm
a
unarian understanding what is the
meaning of Islam that's
why of course respect so so now there is
Islam which every Prophet came with
that's why in the Quran Allah
said Islam the only religion with Allah
and the way of life is Islam so when we
say Jesus was a Muslim Abraham Moses
meaning they were I'm not saying they
follow Prophet Muhammad because Prophet
Muhammad was not alive at that time it
means they submitted to Allah's teaching
according to the teaching of Allah then
just said they submit you can't call
them brother I think that's a little bit
in no no submission what is it
Arab no I I can't I I I can't pronounce
the actual wordl Islam Islam Islam is
subm now now now now when you submit to
one God doesn't mean as I said
Jesus did not submit to Allah he
submitted to Yahweh right he submit to
yeh show me in the New Testament when
Jesus called called Yahweh no no we
don't have to show you in the new
test
know you know you know why you know in
the new this is where I you know the New
Testament is written
Greek I'm one of the people I speak only
deal with the truth brother and I and I
have problems with the fact that it was
written in I I do have problem do you
trust of the New Testament sorry do you
trust the New Testament do I trust the
New Testament yes but I but I don't
believe any book is perfect I don't
believe any book so you every book has
been touched by man every book has been
touched by man it can never be no that's
my op op that's my opinion list
care so you have the Bible in correct
and the earliest manuscript that we have
for the New Testament the full one is
literally 400 years after the original
have all the Codex I know which codex we
have all the stics we have we don't have
and and in and we also have sorry I'll
let you speak you have to let me speak
so what I'm saying I give you the
earliest manuscript that we have for the
new testament which is the siite of
credit card which is in John okay but
I'm
referring I would advise you to watch
debate that occurred between
b a Christian SCH of Manus called
William
Bruce Bruce Willis yes Bruce Willis
Bruce Willis is from Hollywood no no no
no no I'll show you the name here I
always forget the name of the but uh
debate is known it's famous debate the
point here is that both them agree you
cannot really be sure what Jesus said
firstly Jesus spoke a different language
so it's been translated do we know the
translators we don't know them secondly
no no no no you you I'll let you finish
I'll let you finish earliest manuscript
that we have 100 Years After original
writers so do we know the scribes we
don't know them can we trust them if we
don't know them can we trust them the
question to you yes hang on hang on you
don't know who wrote the Quran no no no
you don't know who wrote the Quran I
don't know who wrote the
Bible I'm telling you you going to give
me you going to give me a chance now
because when I was talking I gave you a
chance now you give me a chance how you
going to if if you don't know me would
you give me your credit card with a pin
number why cuz you don't know me you
cannot trust me so if you don't know the
scribes of the Bible how can you trust
them about something which is more
important of the Quan no no before you
know what you doing I think you're way
old than me so I'm going to Uncle I
respect yeah you call me Uncle yeah
Uncle I respect you Uncle you know what
you doing it's like someone telling you
you're a rapist so you tell him but you
kill someone twoo first defend what's
autism I don't do it brother I'm going
to give you but you you you did say
defend your case defend your
case
know you have not give me one second
since you okay go ahead can I speak now
yeah with my right now I'm saying I
challenge you on the what you said after
four centuries we have Christian we have
Christian codex that is before the 4th
Century we do have
Christian we have at least part in part
for instance yeah know that yeah there's
no there there are different Daniel
Wallace and B can we the text of the New
Testament brother you did promise me
that you're going to allow me to I Just
sh you I'll just
show go ahead right now we have
different that is before that time but
let me say this to you let me say this
to you if you want to if you if you want
to deal with
Christianity the most important
thing Jesus don't mention mind we having
a discussion we having a discussion a
Christian this
guy a Christian
don't mention